fluoresence recovery after photo
bleaching is a microscopy based tool to
study molecular
movements it's a confocal based method
which is used to study fluidity of
membrane mobility of membrane proteins
cytoskeletal Dynamics or intracellular
transport so let's say we want to study
if the membrane fluids are membrane
lipids are fluid or not so in order to
do that membrane lipids are stained with
a fluorescent D eventually this
particular Dy would be bleached with a
intense laser and Rec Rec y profile
would be monitored if there is recovery
that would mean that there is a
molecular movement which leads to this
kind of recovery if these are static
then no recovery would happen similar
approaches can be taken to study the
composition of uh membrane fluid
membrane uh lipids also it can be used
to understand how neurotransmitter
containing vesicles are trafficked along
the neuronal processes watch the full
video to know more